but we begin with an american tradition
on this black friday tens of millions of
americans will be shopping online and in
stores after celebrating thanksgiving
this was the scene before sunrise at a
best buy store in woodland park new
jersey which opened to waiting customers
at five in the morning five in the
morning shoppers already spent at least
three and a half million dollars per
minute online yesterday that's according
to adobe analytics more than 108 million
people plan the shop in stores or online
today experts predict a new record in
spending over the holiday season meg
oliver is inside that best buy in new
jersey meg good morning i hope you're
safe
i am safe good morning vlad while today
is officially black friday best buy
started rolling out black friday deals
in october with more sales launching a
week ago but as you mentioned that
didn't stop shoppers from turning out
early today looking for bargains
pre-pandemics stores like this one would
have been opened on thanksgiving day
facing potential supply shortages many
retailers started their holiday sales in
october and have made black friday a
weeks-long event
i'm looking for a laptop
and some other like little electronics
and stuff this morning eager shoppers
looking for the best deals lined up in
the dark just like the old days
i got it
i did it big box stores aren't the only
ones cashing in business has been really
really good marco sejal owns wachong
book sellers in new jersey she says
after struggling to stay open during the
pandemic she's grateful so many
customers have returned in person how
important is black friday to your bottom
line so we used to ignore black friday
but
10 years ago we said you know what we're
going to embrace black friday and we
called it festivus friday so it's become
a really strong day
for us and a fun day well she's not sure
what the it book will be this year
sajell says she and her team are
planning ahead to keep shelves stocked
throughout the holidays we are concerned
about the last massive two-week rush and
having enough product with the supply
chain so we've been encouraging people
to shop early and they are about 60
percent of shoppers said they've already
begun their holiday shopping that's no
surprise with so many stores trying to
entice shoppers to start spending early
with sales offering early access to
deals we've been seeing consumers start
earlier and earlier every year catherine
cullen is with the national retail
federation they predict that holiday
sales during november and december will
grow up to 10.5 percent over 2020 and
consumers will spend up to 859 billion
dollars setting records for both growth
and total amount spent
individual consumers said they plan to
spend about one thousand dollars total
this holiday season it seems like black
friday sales started after halloween
they have been offering their deals
earlier and earlier you know a couple
years ago we were talking about black
november
now we're seeing black friday deals
starting in october and really in those
weeks leading up to thanksgiving
in-person shopping is up more than 14
percent this year and it's expected
about 160 million people are expected to
shop over this holiday weekend that
includes cyber monday so if you're
looking for something specific the
message from big and small retailers
michelle bye early yeah did you get
yours in
i got it all in i got here early i've
been shopping a little bit
we love hearing that meg so glad he
could do two things at once